you made it you made it you made it oh
yeah you made it
it you made it weird with
petees what's happening weirdos uh this
is the return the return of Ls black who
I I don't know I told Val when I got
home after this one I was like I have a
weird
connection with Louis black whenever
we're together we have a great time we
always go deep we always have big laughs
he's just he's a solid sweet kind funny
deeply interesting person and I'm so
glad he's here back on the show he has a
uh special a full special that's
available on uh YouTube right now which
is called tragically I need you you got
to check that out and uh not much not
much else to say we're going to get
right into it I just just want to plug
uh what do I want to plug I have my
monthly Largo show the last one was
incredible it was sold out Sarah
Silverman was there was so fun
incredible show the next one is in
November go to largo-la
docomomo the rest of my tour dates are
at Pete holmes.com I'm going to be in
Bloomington Indiana Washington DC uh and
in Chicago Illinois if you saw me in
Chicago or DC recently this is a new
hour and I'm thrilled with it and I hope
you like it uh so it'll be a different
hour than the one you saw last time I
was in town so go to Pete holes.com for
those and all of the tour dates on the
feeling it tour we're calling this one
the feeling it tour I also have a
Netflix special coming out on October
24th gosh that's very very soon so
please please please uh I love it worked
hard on it I I think it's my best one
yet go on Netflix and watch I am not for
everybody on October 24th and from that
point on so check that out please this
uh this special this episode is brought
To Us by our friends at brain FM I would
just using brain FM this is a new piz
it's a part of my daily creative routine
for years and I'm so happy to be
partnering with them what is it it's
specially curated music that helps you
drop into your focus into your
relaxation for me I use it to get into
that flow state every morning I sit down
at my computer throw on these very head
phones hit Focus hit creative flow lowii
is my favorite genre and boom it drops
me into the pocket ready to work create
and focus without it I find it so much
harder to complete tasks I procrastinate
uh I can't meet deadlines even my own
deadlines but with brain FM I'm
signaling to to my brain literally that
it's time to get things done and it
works what is it on the surface it seems
just like an app that gives you the
perfect gra background music for
Creative work steady reading meditation
relaxation and sleep and that is true it
is incredible music to work or read or
meditate to but under the surface it's
so much more than that brain FM's
composers work hard to create amazing
sounding music that doesn't distract and
uses their patented audio technology to
boost your mental States on demand brain
FM scientists and composers add patterns
to their music that change the patterns
in your brain creating increased blood
flow and electrical activity in the
brain and increasing focus in as little
as 5 minutes regular music is is of
course designed to distract you so
you're constantly having to stop skip
songs change songs pulling you out of
that flow now with brain FM you don't
have to think about it at all you can
stop the skipping brain FM has a wide
variety of sounds and genres from nature
soundscapes to lowy electronic music
that get you in that zone almost
immediately without having to pick the
perfect playlist and it science backat
brain FM actually has the scientific
research to back up their claims through
close collaboration with neuroscientists
and a wide array of field experience
experiments and testing and it's not
made by computers it's made by actual
human multi-instrumentalist composers so
get in that flow get the perfect work
music get those patterns into your brain
to increase that flow and creativity and
that Focus or that relaxation or that
meditation Go to brain. fm/ weird and
you will get 30% off your first year of
brain FM and start getting more done
with less effort and unlock your best
self on demand experience the difference
that the right music can make in your
life brain. fm/ weird for 30% off your
first year all right everybody enjoy the
return of the one and only Lewis Black
get into it here grab that microphone
and
uh let out a concerning cough it's
concerning it's really I've had that
since the fires really can I tell you
something I dated a lady for about a
year and she smoked and I at the time I
was so codependent I'm still you know I
have to keep an eye on it you know what
I mean yeah know I get
it it's not my strongest suit
codependence yeah I'm not a big
codependent no I know I'm a super but it
depends you're a self-reliant depends on
the day of the week is that true yeah
you fluctuate sip that coffee I'll
finish this boring anecdote anyway I I
was so codependent I would I would bum
cigarettes from her I swear to God I
felt bad that she was the only one
smoking no have you ever heard of such a
thing crazy no I I've I've grown I this
is before therapy I'm just turning this
off let me turn mine off do it wow I
really enjoyed talking to you you you
are so out of your [__] mind well I
mean you know as I'm saying this I'm
like I I'm sort of having a a romantic
feeling for that version of myself he
was so good for material now I'm out
there being healthy being like
reasonably balanced but she would
smoke and I would smoke so I wasn't
smoking more than a couple certainly not
even every day y but only a couple and
speaking of coughs and the fires I have
when I laugh really hard now which I
will I I'm going to predict in this hour
I'll cough and it's just because I
smoked a couple cigarettes for a year
off and on we're so fragile I've not
smoked gra that 2000 I've been smoked
since 2017 oh I forgot you were a smoker
I was a smoker so part of it is but I
didn't it didn't really you know had a
cough yeah um and they said that would
go away and it didn't go away but we
when you quit yeah they were like I'm
here to tell you never going to go I
know really and you have no degrees uh
in I don't even need one you can frame
as many pieces of paper this guy frame
as many pieces of paper as you want well
that represents a lot of time in school
it's not just a piece of paper uh but
yes I don't have any degrees Yeah no and
uh but I really but it kicked in we were
in
Wisconsin and and they the the day
afterwards they you know you turn the TV
on and whatever you know Town you're in
and they're going well you know those
fires in Canada really destroyed our air
quality yesterday it was you know really
dangerous for you to be well now you're
telling me you [__]
[__] now we're talking we are so
fragile does that ever occur to you we
were uh we moved outside of the city
we're up in ohigh and Rain almost took
us out rain like we are you living
outside the city and this is just uh we
rent this place to our friend Kate that
right and every every week Kate doesn't
know who the guest is and this week I
said oh boy oh boy Kate's a Jew Kate's a
Jew Kate is Jewish and she gets very
excited for the Jewish guests and I was
like well I have the king Jewish guest I
couldn't wait and I go Louis black and
she gives me the most vacant look and I
go Jesus Christ Kate I go Jesus Christ
and close the door on her as I was
closing the door she went but I was like
how big do you have to be baby yeah well
that's the story that's the way things
are you go away for a you know they lock
you up for a few years with
you know with the pic and then you come
back out even if you come up with your
podcast even with my [__] podcast
yeah yeah yeah in which I don't talk to
anybody except
myself just you just me call that bur
style where you're just ranting yes I
but what I do is read the rants of other
people oh other rants I read I read when
I start about
2016 or something I started on stage
after the show would end on come back
out and I would read rants from people
wait wait don't leave there's more for
10 minutes please sit back down and then
we would broadcast it throughout the
world it was sent throughout the world
for free so somebody could watch it was
my version okay you're not going to give
me a TV show you [__] I'm going to do
this I'm going way back to the beginning
yeah to where I'm standing there with a
script in my hands yeah in front of a
microphone you know and and uh I'm
that's it and doing other people's Rants
and then ranting about their R and then
contributing at times or sometimes you
don't have to disagreeing or sometimes
you're just doing it sometime but most
of a lot of the times they got so good
these rants when it was finally once
they got the hang of it once these these
folks Rel like oh I can write in his
voice which is I'm not a tough voice to
write in no and once you found that
that's a great compliment I think I'm
agreeing and I think there's a great
compliment in there that we should take
a minute to smell CU it's so fragrant
and delicious
if you're easy to all the greats are
easy to impersonate actors and comedians
you're one never thought of it I just
thought of it is kind of like
simple-minded you know like I agree but
I remember even in New York when I was
coming up there was a guy that would go
and I was like i' you know call foul on
the play which is fine maybe he was just
trying you on for a week well that's
what happens and that's what you got to
do I understand well and also is that
other thing that happens when which you
know is a comic you you leave you come
back you know 2 days later you're
working with an opening act and then you
like 3 days after that just something is
stuck in your head and you do something
you are [__] yeah I've seen not not
specifically the words but just you know
something that you pick up my okay the
guy that the man that I'm touring with
right now Matt McCarthy I'm watching
both of us bleed into each other you
know what I mean and we just talk about
it like it's a completely normal
phenomenon like married partners that
look like each other or you ever see two
married people and they're both wearing
Apple watches but they're like a little
too old or maybe they're new or
something you're like you bought that
together you [__] sick [__] you know
what I mean there something kind of
gross about it they're both wearing
hokas oh you both went out and got Hoka
shoes yeah who who who shot first and
then the husband's like I'll wear hocus
I'll wear a peach colored shoe and now
they're doing it see you are fun I'm
just enjoying you're like this
permission for me to be like you goddamn
[__] it's good though no it's healthy
well it is healthy but what's so funny
to me is you're like the you're you're
very sweet to me and you're a very sweet
person I took a compliment just from a
fact I appreciate that Louis I am very
sweet to then you snap yes and to watch
you someone like you snap or Ray Romano
snap yeah you know who's way he's way
further as a
presentational sweet guy yeah yeah yeah
I saw him do this you just as a side bar
yeah this is a sidebar um whatever the
[__] that we can install one so I don't
know what that means I don't it's
something I I think it's when you're in
an airplane and the concession cart is
briefly next to you that's a sidebar
just the only for a moment you're like
on the sidebar and then it moves on we
were in um I was in uh the comedy seller
back before it exploded in the room that
was like a a squash court yes and um uh
and it was me dve Vel there was someone
else who I can't somebody else who you
know immediately and the audience would
know and uh and Ray Romano and there's
like 18 20 30 people in the room and um
and Ray is like in his fifth year of uh
oh this is when Ray is on Ray is big oh
yeah yeah Ray is huge and and Dave is we
we're all kind of you know in our in
some of us are in our sweet spots yeah
yeah yeah and uh that's like Insomniac
Dave that's a similar PE right exactly
yeah yeah so it's a hot table so it's a
hot group of people this a Daily Show
for you too isn't it yeah yeah and also
I was touring and Dave and I had been
kind of put on we if we'd become the
faces of Comedy Central in part because
on Fridays they would do a bunch of
clips and Dave and I would do stuff in
between we were the segue guys can I by
the way say that that sweet time of life
was when only celebrities were on
Instagram meaning like Remember music
videos I was just thinking about this
like [__] uh Cheryl Crow is like a
all I want to do is have some fun she's
drinking a beer in a barn and we're like
oh my God images and music it's cuz she
was the only one who had Instagram you
had to be on TV to be like consumable in
that way and now it who [__] cares
you drop a music video that could be a
guy flying in the space for real and
nobody cares so this is a magical time
you and atel were the only people on
comedy Central's Instagram Instagram
yeah or channel channel and then and
actually and I was and I was doing an
internet interview show with comics and
then until they threw us off some reason
they this has no future Comics talking
for long periods has no future let's
cancel this now so I knew I knew I was
once again if they you know they would
pick up at some point and I'd get [__]
yeah so so it was great you it was
really so it's this great group of know
I'm like all excited so I forget it gets
at first and they just eat it I mean
nothing the audience does care they
don't give a [__] couple more four more
people show up maybe five uh David and
we're watching and we're but but we're
all thinking as we're watching that guy
whoever it was who's funny and there's
that part of your head going oh man it's
it's horrible but it's kind of great
because we never get this is somebody
who never gets [__] over he's getting
[__] over I won't get [__] over yeah
yeah see because I've already watched
him going so I figuring out ways to deal
with the David tell gets up [__] and
Dave is always killed I've never seen
Dave not kill I mean he'll go into a
culde saac but he comes out yeah yeah
sure no he great way to put it just a
suffering culd yeah but he circles
around he circles around comes back out
he did this he circle circle flush then
it's then it's uh wait does he not do
well he does okay oh no he flushes right
down the toilet oh flush bad bad
everybody is really good yeah he no but
not a flush if you're the turd fles his
back yeah cuz you're about to get eaten
by a seat no and he is God so he goes
and it's and the audience now is bigger
and then nothing I mean it's not even
they're not yelling they're not they're
just not a laugh just kind of now you
know it's like we're saying to each
other maybe maybe somebody should go up
and ask if they speak our language yada
yada you know something you know one of
those that they could cuz you know the
guys I'm not kidding is that thing on
it's not not a bit
like somebody check but it's also that
comedy seller thing that you'd have 12
you know 12 Iraqis show up you know true
were 12 Kurds and they didn't speak
English you know they just come there CU
they'd heard right right so that's what
we thought but that that was only there
was a couple of them but it wasn't that
Ray gets up which is where you know now
that we get to the part of the story and
Ray uh Ray starts out and it's not
working and it's his stuff you know and
there's a big you know there's he gets
oh right then zip but in a Madam tuso
sort of way can we do photos they're not
there for the material Madam that's
really wonderful it's wow that's true
that's where I feel like I'm at um
so so he he ends up uh he goes uh and
he's just dying and he's dying and then
he goes after his kids now I've never
heard Ry and I'd been around Ry before
it exploded before the Romano show came
on before his show at the years and he
don't never the family I'd never seen
him go after I mean now he's and he's
swearing about what you know his kids
are shits and D I mean that and it was I
wished it was on tape you know it was
before it was not before but it was you
know nobody was carrying cameras around
everywhere right and it was like
stunning it was like God and it's and it
crack the now we're I'm screaming cuz
it's Ray and this is this is really
making me laugh cuz it's like all of a
sudden you know what's in Dr caligari's
closet well he opens it up and out come
the bats and you know it's even weirder
too yeah your closet is nice and
organized there's lots of sneakers in
there your we're we're familiar with
your Shadow but now Ray Romano yeah who
I who I love feels like he should be
working in an ice cream truck yes is
going like these goddamn kids [__] you
oh twins so I can kill one of them you
know like dark dark [__] very very dark
it was really Splendid to watch and then
uh and he just he you know but the only
ones laughing are those of us like
sitting on the bench yeah seeing a
special thing seeing this is like we're
never this isn't going to happen again
you're not going to see a murderer's row
right and I got up now my concept was
now I know now at this point if if this
hasn't happened it's not going to happen
for for me but I'm going to do one
little thing that might change it and I
walked if you the uh if you the the
comedy seller was shaped like a
rectangle this way yeah so the audience
is this way and literally here to the
door was uh to the other side of the
room was maybe 4050
maybe 80 ft 100 ft yeah and there's a
door there and that's the only way out
it was always one of those things I
thought wow if there's a fire we just
die we die yeah yeah yeah and uh so I I
they announced me and I walked right
back to that door I didn't even walk on
the stage I said uh folks I said you
know I figured out what's going on this
evening I said it's none of the comics
you saw tonight cuz they're great Comics
this is they were unbelievably good and
it's not your called either it's the
stage you're having trouble with the
stage okay that's the that's what's
making this difficult so I am going to
be here and the reason I'm going to be
here is so you won't leave the room
during my ACT I'll be blocking the door
were you on the mic or just projecting I
was just projecting cuz it's a small
room yeah you don't even need it that
you don't need you didn't need did they
laugh nothing nothing at all no nothing
still still nothing zero it was great
and then except for my guys except for
yeah of
course and I I don't even mind well
you're still going to have a body
reaction but if one of the reasons I
love touring with Matt is even if it
goes poorly which it's been going great
but even if it did go poorly we do some
weird uh hell gig together at least he
can see you know what I mean I didn't
get into this business to vanish and
there's nothing lonelier than bomb
and there's no other witness that can go
that was unwinable that's all I need I
don't need to win yeah I just need us to
agree that was unwinable wasn't it
wasn't me it wasn't the CRA just wasn't
in the cards and you know what it's a
it's a phenomenon it doesn't happen more
often that a group of people and there's
just a guy talking aren't rolling La
it's a miracle anytime that it ever
happens it should only be bombs they
should be like I saw a non- bomb it
should be like a newsworthy story that a
comedian killed yeah but we're like we
get spoiled well we do get spoiled and a
lot of it has to do with um the fact
that they they know us so they there's
an expectation they bring that
expectation in the room they expect to
laugh they're going to laugh right the
your idiosyncrasies a lot of our hooks
yeah uh are
idiosyncratic it's the way in which we
present our comedy I'll give you one
Seinfeld yeah his his record I'm telling
you for the last time oh it's the
special as well but the record's better
I'd tell him that to his he knows yeah
they taped it for HBO and it's great but
the record they fil they recorded one of
the best shows of the tour and you're
like he's having fun he's riffing it's
incredible it's a great CD I had it on
CD and I was like this should have been
the special doesn't matter yeah yeah he
knows that I'm not talking [__] no no
but i' I've never heard of the I never
heard that he did nobody's heard it
who's heard of I'm telling you the last
time the album it's such a good record
it's a great comedy record but he goes
up and at this point I'm I'm you know
very very interested in trying comedy or
I I don't I don't think I had tried it
yet and he opens with so what's up with
the cab drivers in the bo huge laugh and
I'm going like what the [__] what is
happening like i' been I go to open mics
you go up on stage and go so what's up
with the cab drivers in the
bo maybe maybe a couple Chuckles but
when you know it's Jerry being Jerry and
you like you're saying like I hope he
does you're one those guys I hope he
does the thing yeah and you do the thing
we're so happy and there's nothing wrong
with that no it's what you know because
it's like uh um you know it's you know
it's
like you you you're you're in in their
face for so long in in communicate with
them for so long whoever the group is
yeah that they see you it's like you're
at the dinner table yeah that you're a
part of the family can I tell you my
standup comedy theater
sure this this occurred to me it's your
show really I can I can look right down
the barrel and do seven minutes of
ads
um no I I'm just excited to see I'll do
let's do them simultaneously I can do
you do yours yeah promo code black I'm
assuming it's hard to know uh use promo
code we or% off 50% off 70%
off you which promo C are you going to
use I was at a I was I was having dinner
this is long long long time ago in
Chicago so I had only been doing stand
up like two or three years and I'm at
dinner and I watched a large dinner
party like 10 12 people and they're all
it's going it's humming it's like a
birthday or something then someone
arrived
late but they're in the group but they
arrived late and there were these
expectations and you know this without
knowing that you know this one whatever
they say is should be funny like we want
it to be funny maybe it won't be but
even the dullest person will be like Los
Angeles traffic we're going to laugh
like to show them that it's okay that
they're late kind of to fold them into
the group but you're also it's this
moment where standup is occurring
organically is my point it's like you're
standing they're seating there's a group
and there's you you're the outlier and
like it's this cultural expectation like
why are you late so the up is kind of
like the formalization of wait why are
you over
there it's like who we're all here what
are you doing up there you're like I
know I should be down there but [__]
I got and you're off that's why so many
of the Great openers I saw Ron White do
an opener and I think he was doing a
little FIB because he his opener was uh
he he was in Chicago and he goes I flew
into Milwaukee cuz my travel agent
doesn't own a map and we were off yeah
but yeah you do la it's B B you know
what I mean you just fly in a small
place but then he does this like
10minute routine about flying in small
planes and it was [__] killer but
that was like the most honest like I'm
here here's what happened like it's it's
natural it's it's the most like the
dinner party setup well that's my
favorite thing that that could possibly
happen is if something if I went and
something [__] up yeah and now I'm
going to deal with the [__] up yep
that's the best it's the best it could
be and then because then you're
doing this is my belief uh about comedy
in part because everybody talks about
everybody it's about you know about do I
start by writing on liners do I start by
doing this punch lines Etc I go no you
start by telling the funny story oh
interesting I think that's what drives
us yeah if we sat around it a this is
one way to look at it this
is but you s when you were in the
cafeteria and you and you and your group
sit down there's four or five of you and
you're not going to believe what
happened right oh well that happened you
shouldn't this happened to me and you're
all sitting there topping each other and
you know what else is built into that
it's like the you weren't thess energy
comedians are trying to harness that
fuel of you weren't there I
remember standup comedy of the book said
I know I'm not even suggesting people
read standup comedy of the book but I I
remember reading stand up the com the
book and one of the things that I liked
about Judy Carter wrote this book oh
that's right yeah is remember Go on
stage this is when there was one book
about standup comedy now there's like a
section but anyway go on stage with the
energy of seeing a friend you've you
haven't seen all day and you couldn't
wait to tell them something right and I
was like [__] brilliant not I hope I
can make them laugh not even I hope I'm
good more like I can't wait to cuz I
remember being in um I studied a
semester in isra in Jerusalem and I went
on this walk it's not a good story but
that's not even the point it when it had
happened it was a great story I got lost
and there used to be little uh throws of
children that would look for lost
tourists and would give them directions
for money and I knew that so I was like
I'm not falling for this [__] like i'
had been in Jerusalem for like four
months at that point I'm like felt like
I was a local so I'm like hey do you
guys know where jafa gate is or
something and they're like where go
where go WG go that that's what they're
saying and they want me now to use them
as an escort and I'm like no no I get it
you guys are going to get I'm using like
sarcas on these children that only speak
probably Arabic I'm like you're going to
give me directions and then I'm going to
give you money I get it they're like
yeah yeah money money money and I'm like
what the [__] is it like I shouldn't
have said any of those words all they
heard was give me directions and I'll
give you money so now they're following
me and I'm like no no no I know where
I'm now they're you know what you know
when you're scared of kids like when
there's a lot of them and they could
assemble like Voltron and [__] take
you out I was afraid of these kids and I
was like no no I'm good I'm good I'm
good and finally we were about to part
ways I I found like a narrow hole that
they couldn't follow me through and one
of the kids threw seeds in my face like
he had been eating some sort of seeded
fruit and he threw the seeds in my face
and now I'm blind I think that back this
point I was corny enough to be like so
that's their strategy you can hear the
side they're going to blind me so I need
their directions you know what I mean
like I thought comedy had to be that way
but the funniest part wasn't my cute
turn at the end the funniest part was
the feeling and I and I hadn't seen my
friends all day and we sat down to
dinner and I was like you're not going
to believe what happened to me and that
was one of my biggest in the wild kills
of my life where I really was like I had
done standup comedy one time at that
point and when I had that when I told
that story and the seeds and all the I
was like I think I can do this so you're
absolutely right it's the
story because I think and tell me what
you think about this standup isn't
necessarily the hardest part isn't
necessarily the jokes it can be maybe
the joke writing in the structure I
think it's finding your own sunlight
inside that Wills you to share it does
that make sense like you need to
manufacture your own motivation yeah to
do it and do it earnestly so it's not
just like hello
there were children and but if I'm like
I want to connect like what do I want
what do I want you to get what do I want
me to get what do I want us to get I
wouldn't call it
sunlight dark Hellfire reflection on the
blood moon mine does not come from
sunlight yeah but it does mine comes
from a Slaughter of the
pigs and the moon reflects in the pools
of blood and you go I have a bit but you
do tell me a little bit about what is
the story cuz you're still doing it
and unless you've been horrible with
your money I'm assuming you don't necess
you're not like just grinding out a
living so why why Louis
why um you're backstage what are you
saying I don't know but I don't know
I've got to check this oh your phone let
me let me I this you're not hearing this
are you no okay good I can hear it yeah
you can hear it let me finish this I'm
sorry about that no please it's just I
don't this is an easy lift this is where
we can be racist if we
want oh that's my impression my loving
impression of my wonderful manager is if
I'm on the set of and he knows this if
I'm on the set of a movie I'll pretend
he's calling me to say that there's
interest in me being in the
movie like I'm in the makeup chair and
I'll answer the phone it's him and I'll
be like hey buddy just letting you know
there's some interest in you being and
I'm like I'm on the set it's it's the
Riff okay what were we saying oh your
motivation my my motivation for what
what's keeping me on the road yeah yeah
yeah I guess let's put it in a way
that'll go viral why are you still doing
this what is the matter with you why
won't you just get low remember that
movie just get low and and clean out at
the house no what what's the story it's
partly I would have been
probably
um off the road in part maybe maybe is
what I say CU I would keep going I'm in
I'm retiring at 70 I'm retiring uh I
literally thought at one time my friend
said you know you said this three years
ago I said well okay well you I didn't
realize I'd come up with another
special and it's so you have a planned
retirement yeah like Tarantino 10 movies
no I my it was literally I I probably
would have uh if it weren't for the
pandemic W wound down I had a kind of an
idea what my one of my arc to be the
pandemic through that Arc in out the
window yeah and so in part uh it's um I
I just wanted to do I wanted I kind of
want to
find the what the Finish is you know
what's the last bit of what's the last
special yeah you know and what do I
really want to after saying all this you
know stuff what is it that I how do I
want to kind of what's my summary and
that's kind of what I'm out there doing
and it's come at kind of a good time you
mean that's your act now that's what I'm
looking for that's what you're looking
for now my act now is a piece of
[__] keep looking I me there are moments
that yeah are are spectacular and then
it's like oh he was so I we saw him up
in the sky and it was really burning
bright and then it then he disappeared
and then there was nothing and then
there was
silence I was just talking about that
when you're building an act it almost
sucks when you get it to a 10 cuz you're
like oh no first of all you didn't know
it was a 10 suddenly you're finding out
it's a 10 in real time oh God and then
you realize nothing after it is going to
be as good as that and you're like and
that was my opener you're like now it's
45 minutes of me looking for another 10
yeah it's a vulnerable place so I've got
you know and the and cuz I don't want to
end on the last one I mean basically the
last two specials were about were
literally
uh my my for me to say this is what I
saw in the last three years yeah this is
what I saw not what you saw not what
your [__] critic head saw not what
you thought about mask not what what I
thought and it had no effect on you at
all because I wasn't even running around
the country I was just in my own head
for for a good for a good year right
right you know and so so to me it was a
book end of of just kind of which I
never even you know I didn't get into
doing this in part to to leave a history
behind but that's in part what I've said
somebody ought to just talk about it
from an individual basis and that's what
I did yeah and and and uh and then so it
was like I've got to do I got to get go
back to doing one more out of that [__]
and naughty and topical at all yeah
broad Strokes is that am I hearing well
topical still I'm topical in the sense
that um we've we' we've reached this
level of that I've been talking about
before the P it was where we were before
the pandemic and where we are now uh
which is how do you saiz something
that's already satiric yeah yeah yeah
really tricky yeah and that's what I'm
doing on stage trying to figure that out
and if you have some time off I'm more
than will give you a couple of bucks to
a free hot lunch a hot seated lunch it's
an interesting point like obviously you
know do you know the movie Idiocracy yes
I bet there would be no comedians in
that world you know what I mean yeah
isn't that kind I've never considered
that that if the president is watering
the crops with energy drinks and he
shoots a gun at the opening of his
statement and he's a wrestler
essentially and everything's nuts like
it wouldn't even make sense to be like
have you seen this like cuz it it would
be so saturated well it's kind of like I
the thing in part I've said and it's and
it's trying to figure out where it's
once again what you were saying the T
it's figuring out where you say it in
the in the the during the time that
you're on the stage which is is the uh I
don't know why I'm here you already know
the joke yeah yeah yeah and you do know
the joke and then when I tell you the
joke you're not laughing at the joke
because that's when it becomes painful
wow interesting you know and that
otherwise you know I I I mean I was
going on stage and going uh um which I
would literally say
um Hershel Walker pause and that's all I
got to
say I mean it was
extraordinary in a bad way like you you
like that or you didn't you loved it I
loved it because it reminds me of The
Twilight Zone the guys like I want to be
the Best comedian in the world and they
laughed at any time no this was called
This is they got the j i you say nothing
about Hera Walker other than his name
for them to know all of how psychotic it
was that this man and then if I I'd
sprinkle out a little of the you know
for those in the audience who didn't
know why the others were laughing yeah
yeah yeah it's interesting you you're
cashing in on a it's a sweet spot in
comedy yeah they know where you it's
like they're in the theme park and we
know and I can hear that in the audience
of your of your of this last special
they know where you're going and they
want to and they want to go there and
that's a very special place it's a
tricky thing when they don't know who
you are and you I mean I think about
that all the time yeah I mean what a
bummer yeah and I still face crowds that
have no idea who I am don't get me wrong
I'm just saying like to only ever go up
for crowds that are like prove it and
you're like although it does make you
good I guess yeah no but you know but
but I think uh it's interesting that we
talked about that
um was something I wanted to about the
about telling the story yeah okay
because I think um any any kid who's
listening
uh who wants to do it you know really
that it the other thing not just the
earnest you know not just I really got
to tell the story that you tell that
funny story don't worry about where the
punchlines are you've told the story a
100 times yeah you know it's funny it's
generally you can find it in if you were
if you had a Catholic upbringing boom a
family that's dysfunctional boom here's
a good one bad blind date
wooo and when I would teach when I
because I would kind of teach the
experience of standup
not I'm going to make you a stand up I
[__] you I'm you're not going to you do
that on your own yet you know don't call
me up to you yeah uh but you know to to
to to just give them that it was for
actors really to give them that so that
they'd come out with a monologue so they
weren't doing you know as you like it
and stuff like that and and that what
they got but but the stories that I
heard were just spectacular right I mean
there were there were stories you might
never hear in a club ever but it gave
them a sense of what it's like to you
know if if what it's like to be funny on
stage because all they're doing is
taking the other thing and you know this
from what you were saying earlier is
that the only difference between uh the
the the sitting around the table the guy
goes you know I could I could be a comic
I said if you can walk the five feet
from that from the table and get on the
stage and face the audience it's five
the only difference between you here and
you there is five feet it's a big five
feet though it's a huge 5T it's a moat
and it's filled with [__] and
sharks it's a
moat well you know what's interesting
man to unpack that a little bit cuz I I
take issue with the guy and it's it's an
Italian restaurant it's my dad's friend
he's sitting back he really painted a
picture for me there Camari there's
cigarette out and the lemon he's like I
could do that and I'm like you know what
see when you got actors to do a
monologue from their life and they could
do it and it gave them the experience of
being funny one of the reasons they were
able to do it was they could um keep the
fire alive of how they felt this goes
back to what we're saying if you go up
on stage what happens to that same guy
he gets nervous it's like okay a
magician I could teach you a magic trick
the real magic is to regulate your heart
rate
and slow it down this is why David bla
is like do you have some glasses like
he's really slow cuz he's calming
himself down I love do I love doing
magic but when I do it my handshake
because I get so adrenaline just for fun
for kids and stuff like for funsies
because don't start doing it now in well
I'm looking for an
angle It's hard out there that's the
worst like the worst advice I got try
magic all right can I do it no but like
when you Go on stage that hard 5T that
same story the nerves the first thing
the nerves push out is your attitude is
your how do you feel in that story your
ability to remember so you have to be
like calm like that story I didn't
really tell it but like of getting lost
in Jerusalem was easy to tell because it
had just happened to me but if I told
that guy that told the story at the
dinner tell that story on like Saturday
night at 8 o00 and it's Tuesday I think
can you keep it hot long enough to tell
it and also how do you start like it's
really hard I know you know this but
it's
like a great story like that should open
with like a I'm not saying this is it
but it's like anybody here ever get uh
dried fruit thrown in their face by an
Israeli kid like is a way in and then
the laugh puts them at ease and you go
like I got lost I got really lost
there's what I should really start here
there these gaggles of children murders
really like crows of children going
around the old city of Jerusalem and
they want tourist to get lost that's
part one but you see you have to be like
compelling part one tells me tells the
audience like I know where I'm going I'm
flying the plane but if I just went on
stage and was like I got lost like if
they're not
saying why are you late to dinner that's
the in the standup has to create the in
out of nothing right in fact bad standup
to me when I have soft shows I'm like
you ever been doing stand up probably
not in a while I'm imagining but you're
going like why am I I telling these
people about my life that's how it feels
to bomb is they're just like why are you
telling us this and on bad nights I go
like I agree like you're right it's
weird that I'm like my daughter and I
were at a birthday party and she got
lost like what who cares if it's not
going well Suddenly It's like who cares
if it's going great you're like of
course you wanted to know about my
daughter but if it's going badly you're
like a weird guy at a bus stop yeah my
daughter I'll tell you got to get a
relash yeah and then but that for us is
because then we get down
to uh there's a math to Comedy there's a
c not that there comedy is math but
there is a there is it's an equation
yeah and so that when you're talking
about you like your daughter it's like
also it's finding that point where you
can set it up so that you don't have
that thought yes you know engages them
that's why going like saying you ever
gotten lost in the old city J some
deduit thrown in your face like at least
that's acknowledging them and giving
them a in they want a in this is Ron
White going like I I just flew into
Milwaukee cuz my travel agent doesn't
own a map yeah is like I'm in awe of an
opener like that cuz you don't even have
to know him or care about him to know oh
I've flown into a small airport before
or what an idiot where's this going how
was that it must have been a 10-minute
flight it's the most
relatable I mean when I hear bits like
that I'm like why am I almost
exclusively talking about my parents
getting older cuz that immediately it's
like either you understand that or you
don't well and if you are it's you know
it your audience I'm going to tell you
from my experience of bringing my
parents into the ACT you know it was
that they uh they all relate to it and
it's also because we don't talk about it
I know at all as a country I know and
and your generation my My Generation
which is different from yours My
Generation has already [__] things
because they knew my group knew and
hasn't dealt with the problem your
groups watching it they're not dealing
with the problem we're all kind of
standing around going well tough ski
shitsky you get old oh it's too bad how
you hear a dark one oh yeah I feel like
this whole the philosophy of this whole
world question mark is not me not today
we see terrible things happening and you
go not me not today like people are
getting old people are dying not me not
today and what's [__] crazy is one
day you go oh it's me and that's that's
a weird way to live whereas there have
been cultures that do have appreciation
for the dying process for the aging
process I I I know I sound like Andy
Rooney right now but like Elders like it
was folded into society but we're like
to quote romdas he was like paint paint
the red leaves green paint them green
you know like I know a couple people in
their 90s and they're they're out there
wearing [__] Under Armour jackets and
I'm like can we get this man some
goddamn corduroy and a pipe and little
slippers I need a [__] old guy I
don't need [__]
goddamn I'm trying to Kevin Federline
but he's 90 I don't need that yeah but
we don't like it so I don't blame them
for trying to blend in well because and
also because uh the um as you our um our
culture doesn't take in the old it's
literally okay oh yeah you know you you
you literally get a Wi-Fi signal off of
them somehow then would love them if a
group of four old people generated a
strong 5G signal would' be like ah I
love the
elderly I'm streaming all over here
they're streaming in their pants I'm
streaming over here I'm going to use
that that's really that's perfect that
is the the best one I ever heard about
the the elderly which you may have heard
was Dave um God damn it Dave oh [__]
David damn
Feldman and I love that as someone I
don't know oh Feldman I don't know who
is Who David Feldman maybe I do know him
you know you don't know him you may
not he was he worked out here for a
number of years he moved back to New
he's a comic yeah com okay now I'm
embarrassed I thought it was someone in
con oh no no but he's but he's well I
mean he and now he's got a a podcast
thing that he does and he's but he's
been he's one of those seriously dark
funny comics who was working out here
and uh um and and and he's gotten I and
I I think felman's gotten like an Emmy I
forget for which show oh that's what
he's screaming at the radio as he's
listening to this I have an Emy yes he's
he's really very but his was uh and this
is 25 30 years ago about um uh you know
that we have a you know there's a was
there was a food shortage problem at
that point there was some sort of you
know we've got these people they're not
eating is is you know we've got all of
these people in uh in assisted living
and uh these programs and you know I
think it's time we we just well we eat
them I'm really not doing I'm not doing
it justice I really am not he had a
wonderful setup and the whole punchline
was eat the eat the elderly yeah you
know it serves a purpose and and it
really nailed I mean 30 years ago he
Nails what we're up against because
nobody nobody because it's like you
become I've experienced it I
literally the pandemic did the the when
it got really got to me was is that um
when they kept going um and if you're
over the age of
70 uh you know you're um you know you're
more susceptible to this but what it was
was is that what they kept saying was um
you're old I said I didn't [__] know
I was old until these [__] every day
blasting it out on CNN anywhere other
the the older part of our the the senior
citizens the the yada y whatever you
wanted to call us yeah the rubbish you
know the ones that we're going to have
to [__] keep alive you get to get in
line for what the [__] I didn't even
know I wouldn't have thought of running
down to the goddamn thing you [__]
[__] and my my father had a great
line one of the the first time the first
tip off that what you have to look
forward to in your senior years he said
he said until I walked downstairs for
breakfast living in an independent and
assisted living place they were an
independent living He says until I go
downstairs and have breakfast and look
around I he said I have no concept that
I'm old really then I look around and go
holy
God I think I see that happen to my
parents yeah all my setups by the way
are I don't think my parents know how
old they are that's the setup to every
single one of them my mom this is going
to sound weird old are they my I don't
know and that's the opening is I go my
parents are 80 wow you're going to like
this I go my parents are 80 something I
don't know we're not a family like that
and I go you want to watch my dad have a
panic attack ask him how old is Peter
he'll walk through a wall he'll walk
through a wall to avoid that
confrontation they have no [__] idea
they're foggy on the exact day of my
birthday that's real I get birthday
cards yeah yeah well my but my parents
my mother especially just said um that's
always been [__] she birthdays were
[__] Mother's Day I thought she was
like we didn't even know oh no she just
meant it's all [__] no my family's
like that and this actually I hope it
comes out my family stuff works when I
remember I love them it's weird that I
have to everything I'm saying is like ah
these [__] old people but I have to
hold on to this I keep saying Ember and
fire but like I have to hold on to
something inside of me or the jokes
don't work like I have to stay in touch
with so when I say we're not a family
like that that see this is what I'm
talking about the math I'm saying to the
audience we're a different kind of
family we're like kind of we break each
other's balls we're we're so I'm allowed
to make fun of my mom yeah and then I
make fun of my mom cuz she can't Point
her fingers like this but she's going
around pointing God love her she's
pointing at stuff I'm at a table there's
50 things on the table she goes Peter
what is that I'm like I don't what
Gonzo's nose Ma I don't know what that
is but I have the same thing I I say
this in the setup I have this it's
called dupin contracture I the same
thing so I but I added that to the setup
to again give me permission to make fun
of it cuz I'm like making fun of my
parents for being old is sort of just
making in my opinion making fun of Aging
it's it's something that's it's
understood that it's going to happen to
all of us or something worse so like I
feel like if gives us a green light do
you feel that way yeah and I also think
that the audience you you don't even
need to set it up for them because I
mean at least for my experience yeah and
because I'm much funnier than
you no I love but it is but it is just
from my experience of talking about mine
for so long you know it was like uh that
I'll be selling my like it started with
there was a stupid joke my parents my
parents showed up a lot of the times
that I was doing shows you know if I was
in this area so they would come and go
to the casino and gamble and stuff they
come to the show they would come to the
show yeah I mean I would bring them in
they they would my mother this was the
level at which my parents might well I
was working up at uh up at Mohan sun and
I had a and I they had a really nice
Cabaret room as they called it and it
was like 350 seats and I worked there
like five nights four nights five it was
great my parents came up they were live
in Maryland they would come up get get
the train up they [__] meet them at
the the train station pick them up in a
limo take them over there they'd have a
nice room everything was great by the
way Casino like hospitality is the only
way to include your parents yes you know
what I mean like I need a man with a
sign and I need them to grab my mom they
flew in to see us and I sent a car I was
like this is foolproof sent a car
they're car we can't find the car I'm
calling my dad's phone it's forwarding
to his business line I can't even get
them on the phone they just went without
the car I dropped hundreds of dollars
they didn't take it no it didn't work I
need mgan son to blow dart my mother
throw her in the trunk basically and
then there's a big gold car which makes
it you know easier to find yeah really
than the ones that look like a hearse
and they would love yeah that's right
they would love it too by a man in a
shiny brimmed cap being like Mr Holmes
this way it's it would be so fun for my
parents well it's really that was the
thing so they they would get in that
and come to me at moan and that we had
you know it was great and then they and
it wasn't like we would hang out they
would literally it was we did this this
and then boom they shuffled off they
shuffled off and uh uh and then I got
they mgan son took me out of there and
put me in the arena a couple of times at
the big room it's 10,000 seats which is
the most I'd ever played 8,000 to 10,000
yeah and I don't do those kind of rooms
and I've never been that big of a comic
and uh but they really did and it was a
great and my mother went what I said
well we're just going to do the one
night you're not going to be in the no
no this is really she's mad that you're
not in the Cabaret room but we had it
all planned now yeah we have five nights
now you're taking it down and I'm going
here's what I'm going to do you can
spend the five nights I'm going to pay
for the room wa okay so they moved it to
one night in the arena instead of five
nights in the anded more vac least they
wanted the that was what was great to
them not that I was in the casino not
that I was in The Cabaret no they had
five I'm G to pay for it I'm going to
get you I'm even going to get you a
better room than it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it's they're playing on a
different uh board I think same pieces
different board yeah but it was really
that kind of a of a thing with my folks
it was really uh it but but they were
always they were always there but the
the joke and they could like the show
they would enjoy the show oh yeah my
yeah really yeah they loved it I mean my
parents really got a kick out of it I
think that's so great well my mother
would say you know it just came to the
point where my mother's going you know
you owe me some money for this act you
know and you go like I wouldn't be doing
this if you had behaved
better I'm just kidding but she was an
early investor she built the factory but
now the factory is up and running really
who cares if you laid the brick she
Brick Layers don't make
residuals strike all you want no Brick
Layers getting residuals she but they
really so one of my first jokes was that
uh you know that um what's interesting
is to to realize that that uh I would
you know I said you know my parents are
here tonight and you know after the show
if you'd like at the merch table you'll
actually be able to purchase them
they're the size of salt and pepper
shakers that is that was and as soon as
you got but that's like a stupid [__]
aging joke that's a 10 out of 10 I love
that they boom it's already you know
what I mean they get it folks get
because we're all in
that it's it's older kid it's older it's
you talking about children your children
or you talking about your parent you've
already got the the hook is already
there yeah I agree I agree it's a sweet
spot but big I said that too he was like
Comics are come into their own in their
40s he's like the 40s is the funniest
time I think mortality is part of that
you're getting older and falling apart a
little bit and you you know you've made
your in case if you have kids you've
made your Replacements and you're
watching your parents uh die I mean like
I know it's taking a long time but
you're you're watching it it's and it's
even saying that I I bet people are
reeling that I'm like you can't say
you're watching your parent side but
it's like but that's what it is it's
taking a long time but it's a slow
slowing down let's say that can we say
that it's a you have to watch your
friends slowing down what does that well
it was crazy with my parents because you
they my mother was was even when they
were hitting near the early 90s there
was never a sense from them well we're
going to see we're going to see in six
weeks we're going to see in six months
never ever a sense of like this is the
last time yeah yeah yeah never I mean it
was like you and it was part of my brain
was just like it didn't and as a result
it never dawned on me because it was
really like they they are really
committed they're the CEOs I mean and
they brought you life like they say I I
bet that's true there's a little boy in
you that goes that's true it's true
they're going to be and they were and my
mother was even 101 102 you're thinking
okay and and it was only during the
pandemic it was the first time ever yeah
that when the phone rang I thought oh
this is it yeah yeah yeah that's
interesting I'm the I'm the opposite
every time because I only call my folks
I don't know what's going on I mean I
think I do but it would take it would
take about s weeks of non-stop talking
to explain if you want I can switch
seats I'll lay down you lay down no but
I when on my new special that's coming
out I have a joke about when my mom
calls I always go who fell who died or
worse she just wants to talk like that's
that's that was the bit so we're a
morbid family in that sense and also I
remember my dad being in his 50s would
visit Boston were leaving and it'd go
see you next time God willing you we
don't know we don't know and I would was
like wow my dad is I and I can relate to
this he's a he's a you need a
meteorologist like what's going on is
reality and if he was feeling dark in
that moment it like some of that's going
to reach out and be like you never know
so what you what I was hearing I think
was almost like a Irish poet level like
oh this this life she's not promised to
us is it you know what I mean like like
this Melancholy that he didn't have an
artistic outlet for thank God we do yeah
because where he let it out was me
walking out of the house bye Dad see you
next time God willing I'm like Jesus get
this man a notebook get this man a quill
pen and a quiet desk you know which okay
so your parents are both passed now yeah
so when did your dad die how old was he
101 jeez he was the freeway unbelievable
we're here in Los Angeles that's a local
joke he was
freway well God he's not going to make
405 let's be honest
but but 101 101 jez and he paint and the
other thing about artistic my father uh
when he retire he retired he left the
gig he was he
was left government uh and left the
government and um and he over principles
and uh and then and then started doing
what he always wanted to do which was be
an artist no kidding so yeah which is
pretty remarkable how when did he quit
government 60
oh 62 63 I'm so happy I thought you were
going to be like 98 99 no he he got out
oh no he got out I bet that's why he
lived so long well it's part of it for
sure because he uh 61 62 he um he then
started he apprenticed himself to a guy
and did stained glass no kidding and did
that until he went and then he started
to take painting at the same time cuz he
said he knew that it was just he wanted
to do more and he you know the stained
glasses a lot I mean he was cutting it
he was doing all that stuff in his up
until he was 70 and then he re and he
was starting to paint then and realized
that I can I can paint I can get this
out faster and yeah we don't need to
bring dyed glass into this yeah and he
painted until he was I think 83 84 85 I
think I keep thinking but I think it was
83 and hundreds of paintings W and um
are they good well you know the the he's
dead you can tell me
dark I didn't quite understand uh
understand them because they're very he
it's um he called it hard edged
abstractionism so it's it's geometrical
shapes and Designs my father was a
mechanical engineer so he thought a lot
that way and and then his teacher who he
had two teachers there were a husband
and wife at the junior college and both
you know not really pretty good teach
really pretty good artists I mean I
impressed with their work but but but
the the teacher was really impressed
with my father's work and he later God
my D must have been 90 at this point did
a retrospective of his work at the
college wow and he because he said your
father never they finally built a space
big enough he said you know your
father's big paintings uh were never
shown properly and I wanted them people
to see them and he said because they
needed he said your father's was
painting for his stuff should have gone
on buildings and I went in there to look
and I went oh [__] now I get it no
kidding wow remarkable so he's doing
huge paintings well I mean there were
big paintings and then he said look at
it and imagine it on you know you take
that yeah cuz he said the the canvas
kind of contained what he what was going
on but then again we if the uh in the
special if you oh behind you that's
that's his painting no way yeah I really
admired your background I thought that
was an excellent background yeah so your
dad is painted that and that and we're
and we're turning it into a scarf
actually we are really yeah sounds like
a lie and we're turning it into a scarf
and all of the proceeds will go to uh we
we'll send all the stuff to charity it's
remarkable wow cuz it's a beautiful
scarf he had all of this stuff I've got
about 130 paintings that I've kept aside
and due to that [__] pandemic I've
not been able to take the time to to put
up a you know I want to do a showing of
his stuff and I then and then kind of
want to auction the stuff off because I
think it's it's good it should be in
people's homes yeah yeah you know all my
friends wanted a painting he and uh a
lot of his stained glass was he did a
you know because I've did theater he had
a comedy a comedy and tragedy uh masks
on a big piece of stained glass I mean
he's unbelievable what how did that
impact I mean as you're saying this look
I love my dad and if my dad put on a
beret tomorrow and was like There's
Something Beautiful Inside Me Peter I
would [__] I'd be I'd be happy for him F
forget what I I'd be because I know you
and I both know how good it feels to
have a purpose to have a drive to to
make something you have to Greenlight it
you have to say like I'm worthy so that
means your dad did some work to get
things flowing enough to produce and
that that has to make you really h i
mean it's making me happy for your day
yeah no it was great and uh and he lo
you know and he was going to school he
was going to school three times a week
and four painting yeah just and he uh
and the best was God he been doing it
for been painting about four or five
years they did a showing of all of the
student work and somebody broke into the
museum and stole two of the two
paintings and they were both h is oh my
god well there's kind of a compliment
there isn't he said I said what are you
thinking that he said there's he said
there's a thief out there with great
taste yes this is where we find out it
was your dad we find out he put on an
old school cat burglar know I really did
wonder I if but it's PR only two
paintings were sold and they were right
next to a mayet they took they took the
black well what your dad's name isn't
black was it
no it was uh it it was black and and
then it was black it became black oh it
did Oh I thought you changed your name
no like Michael Ian Black the other the
Lesser black say that in I did not
change right though thank God they did
change it from black yeah black nobody
wants that I would have been I would
have been an asthmatic with a last name
like
that and what was his dying process like
were you there was it something you
experienced no it it was this slow
I mean cuz he uh he just got weaker at a
heart thing that uh and he just um you
have a condition where it's been beating
for 101 years yeah really but he just he
faded out but you know that was it you
know he kind of the hearing started to
go but he just my father was all
all my father uh was like living with
Buddha my father had a smile on his face
99% of the time like but not like one of
those goofy [__] yeah yeah yeah Walmart
greeter he he had figured something out
something Serene yeah yeah and he always
had it and it was unbelievable do you
think he knew himself sort of in a
spiritual way yeah you do yeah I do
because because that doesn't happen
nobody's going around smiling unless to
your point there was like a 1950s sacran
disgusting
grotesque
he kind of at peace and then or as I
said he he had another joke way early on
in my Act was that way before you know
when I was you know way way early on but
I was still finding myself on stage one
was is that he was I just thought he was
he he had a dirty movie running in his
head all the time that is very good my
dad's just seems fine he's just watching
deep thr yeah I mean all and he just I
mean cuz he would say things like uh you
know he said you the the only the only
regret I have in terms of my skill as a
mechanical engineer this was
unbelievable I'd have to go you can't
you can't really say this alowed to a
lot of people that he said you know I
wish I had developed an instrument uh
that could measure
cleavage I went what what the [__] are
you talking about he said no one has
really measured it and it needs to be me
measure needs to be Quantified yes that
is very funny my father would just my
father love breasts so he
just it's on his Epitaph you write the
inscription on the EP really small so
you have to lean down and show CLE I'm
going to say I'm I'm actually trying to
figure out what to put on the tombstone
for the two of them and uh it was my
father loves breast that's good and then
my and and then it was uh and then I was
going to write on the next and and I was
allergic to my mother's breast milk you
were yeah which is always a clear sign
that something's going to go [__]
wrong that is isn't that crazy a
comedian's that's like ask an AI to
write a oneline comedian origin story
and I've never used the joke L black was
allergic to his mother's breast milk and
here's nine
[Laughter]
specials this episode is brought To Us
by our friend at better help I don't
know about you guys but the holiday
season every single year if you listen
to the show you know this is a difficult
time for me something about it memories
feelings all this stuff comes up it is
very very complicated it can make me sad
it can make me stress and that's not
unusual this time of year can be a lot
and it's natural to feel some sadness or
anxiety about it but adding something
new and positive to your life can
counteract some of those feelings and
take it from me therapy can be a bright
spot amidst all of this stress and this
change something to look forward to to
make you feel more grounded and to give
you the tools to manage everything
that's going on I in my personal life
and Val as well we have both benefited
so much from talk therapy it's magical
it meaning it's greater than the sum of
its parts it seems like just two people
in a room talking but there's something
in the human condition that benefits
from it so so deeply whether you need to
set boundaries coping skills if you need
to find a a version of your best self to
strive for having a therapist in your
corner to guide you and to help you is
huge it isn't just for those who' have
experienced major trauma it's for
everyday stuff I got into therapy
because I didn't know how to lovingly
and compassionately end a relationship
and put up boundaries with my family and
it's made a world of difference so if
you're thinking of starting therapy give
better help a try couldn't be easier
it's entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire and get matched with a
licensed licensed therapist and you can
even switch therapist at anytime for no
additional charge so find the bright
spot this season with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com weiro toay to get 10% off
your first month that's better
hp.com weirdo support yourself support
this show also it is brought To Us by
our friends at next Evo which is a huge
partner in my own stress coping strategy
and my sleep coping strategy meaning
before I even get into this so many
people say when they want to try CBD
that they didn't feel it uh they don't
know how much to take and next Evo is
the only company that I've worked with
that have actually figured this out you
start absorbing these gummies in just 10
minutes so you know within 10 minutes
how you feel whether you need more and
you can dial it in just right it is
called smart sorb technology and only
NEX Evo has that proven allnatural
gummies that absorb four times better
than most oil-based products with that
SM smart sorb technology so
transitioning from these lazy days in
the summer to the crazy fall schedule
can make uh your Wellness routine
getting back on track feel impossible
but you can sleep great and stress less
by upgrading your CBD as I said regular
CBD oil doesn't mix well with your water
based body but next Evo Naturals are
clinically proven to help your body
absorb four times better than oil so
when you need to de-stress or sleep
better this fall reach for the fast
acting CBD products from next Evo as you
guys know I love their stress formula
the stress gummies uh are incredible
they mixed with ashwagandha which is a
helps you cope with stress ease into a
feeling of well-being in your body and
relaxation mixing with the CBD it is
absolutely absolutely a game Cher and
they work fast so their stress gummies
are incredible and their sleep gummies
are also incredible so try both why not
stress and sleep two things we need to
dial in get more Z's and more Zen in
your life upgrade to better natural
solutions from next Evo Naturals go to
next evo.com and use promo code weird to
get 25% off that's 25% off at
neext
v.com and use promo code weird all right
everybody back to
LS you never did a joke about it I still
still have not I haven't figured out
what the joke is
exactly you know yeah I know I it's
almost like it's almost self-contained
it is you know well going back to Magic
there's actually something in Magic
where a trick can't be too impossible
you know like if I were going to make
this disappear I would cover it right
and it it turns out even if I could just
make it disappear in front of you you'd
actually prefer this version the way
that the the story making brain works
would rather the I wonder what happened
when it was buying that car that's the
fun that's the titilation like if I just
went like that I mean yeah but that's
kind of he was allergic to breast milk
to me it's like already a satire and why
would you saze it going back to your
point earlier so your dad
was he a spiritual
person not not um can I say that I don't
need him to be not that you need me to
need it but I'm just sort of like people
find themselves with no help yeah no he
he didn't um he didn't have that we were
we went to uh this is how spiritually
was in terms of intelligence was is I'm
going to get bar mitz when me and my
brother are bitching about having to go
to Sunday school until we're 15 you know
confirmation yeah and uh you had it both
ways yeah I was SP mitford and then you
graduate and they so they you know
Catholic and Jewish I mean no no Jewish
oh Jewish confirmation Jewish conf know
you guys I'm just kidding I make an
accusation I didn't know you guys were
uh sneaking around taking that from the
Catholic yeah we did we grabbed that and
I think it was just they they just
looked at it as oh that's another way we
can get rid of them on on
Sunday and it was on Sunday wow yeah so
we went to and he said here's what we're
going to do they would have an adult
class every every time so he said I'm
going to take you and your brother
you're going to do this and we're going
to go through all this and and I thought
in the end I thought that was phenomenal
as much as I bitched all the way through
it I thought it was really good to be I
think for Catholics the one thing that
Catholic and the Jew get out of it is
they're taken out of the public y out of
the whole Public Square to get us sense
of what it's like to be other which
gives you an empathy for those who are
other and so but he said he goes so
here's what we're going to do you finish
and uh I'm going to finish if when you
finish and you're done you're done you
don't have to worry about we're not
going back uh when my brother finishes
he's done and when and and then I will
decide if I'm done H and that's and I
will if if I will continue to go or I
will qu and he quit we all quit the
whole family the whole family he did it
as a family for once you did something
as a family you quit church or Temple I
Temple yeah and then where do
you cuz this idea of your dad being this
little Serene and I understand that he
had human emotion you want to hear this
this
will get you the the hook for and if I
say that again just punch me do hook do
hook um we found a word what's the word
today mine is fire in your Bing a flame
or a sun yours is look it's okay it's
what happens this is an energy Vortex
and people get stuck on this show a lot
in certain metaphors my father this is a
great story and I and I do love to tell
it my father was um a mechanical
engineer and designed sea mines the
mines that you put oh yeah uh in your
Harbor to protect your Harbor from
submarines and bad buoys we call call
him
yeah whoops aoy that's what we call him
don't don't touch those so he was behind
that and that's what he did and he never
felt and then
during when the war ended and he was
working in for the defense department uh
doing this he he uh he tried to get work
at a variety of um like Bendix
Corporation frigid a you the mayag it's
hard to walk into M tag and be like you
guys have a secure Harbor yeah well well
it was interesting they were they
all everybody was making weapons so it
was literally we're not we're not doing
that stuff you can come here and make
weapons or also you know or he wasn't
getting the jobs because it was the it
was really still um there was an
anti-Semitism thing going on and when
they meet him that would he wouldn't get
the job job and and my father was not a
big like let's look under every Rock for
anti-Semitism it was just that's the way
it was and uh so he kept working and he
had no he said he and he could um he he
felt comfortable doing that uh uh in ter
morally comfortable because they were uh
defensive weapons MH so he didn't feel
any guilt about it and uh my mother
started screaming about the war in
Vietnam and my father said well you
don't really know because you you know
you this is based on a the Gulf of tonan
resolution based on the Geneva
courts and he said I'm going to read
those and when I finish reading them
I'll let you know what I think and then
we'll decide if we're going to quit as a
family well pretty close because what
happened was is he nobody that I know of
nobody no I've I've stated this on it
numerous times uh it it's in the book I
wrote I said you know you know nobody
else has ever come forward and said I
said nobody else I know has read the
Geneva courts my father came home with
this little blue book and read the
entire Geneva courts more people have
read the instructions for a Honda
Court Geneva herself haven't read the
Geneva Court okay yeah yeah so yeah know
I'm I'm so with you so he read the he
read it wow and he said um there is abs
absolutely nothing in this that uh
supports the the uh what they say should
be this is this there's no reason we
should be at war with them on the basis
of this this Gul of Tong resolution is
[__] wow and it's there there's
nothing in here that that should have
motivated us to go to war
nothing and then with this is a recipe
for a Tiramisu guys are we
kn this beautiful story and I keep
peppering my my perfect it's that way
they'll listen to
it it's true it is God he's still going
STI around the tear
the you go there'll be two recipes at
the end of the
[Laughter]
show one is for moral courage and the
others for a delightful T
su he ends up he heads up they mine
hyong
Harbor and so now they've used his yeah
his you see Minds as an offensive weapon
yeah and uh and then within 3 months he
uh were sitting around he says uh uh
your mother and I have talked and I've
made the decision I'm not going to work
for the government anymore and they're
retiring wow and I was like Jesus that's
extraordinary that is that's unheard of
and it was during got to realize you
know I'm at school I
1970 yeah it's not looking promising for
you yeah boy nobody's like we're going
to lean on this boy yeah no it's I'm I'm
heading to be a playwright exactly this
guy's smoking cigarettes and looking at
a studio apartment Window I don't know
if we can retire on Old Le so so it was
a risk it wasn't just I think I'll
retire now well I mean I was I was
finishing up school so that was my
brother still had two years so it was
not uh it was pretty remarkable that he
uh he walked away and it was huge for me
because it probably uh made me made it
determined that uh in many ways for me
that I was going to make choices on the
basis of what I wanted to do what as
opposed to what uh I I think I should be
doing yeah you know what's interesting
as you're telling that wonderful story
reading stuff right like I just I I love
Adam McKay's movies I just rewatched The
Big Short and then I was I loved it so
much it was probably my fifth time
seeing it and then I rewatched I just
watched part of it I just did it's oh
it's a really and that and you forget
how um that cast is incredible cast is
incredible there's Kendall Roy before
anybody knew Kendall Roy being a
completely different guy by the way
you're like oh my God some people are
acting I'm and stuff there's Pete and
he's wearing a red shirt there's Pete
and he's wearing a blue shirt this guy's
a different guy different like
mannerisms it crazy anyway we talk about
that Jeffrey Jeffree strong Jeremy
Strong sorry sorry but you know he's
such a shape shifter he could be a jerem
or Jeffrey it doesn't matter uh I'm
never wrong I'm just kidding but that
movie uh and and the the people that
shorted the housing market crash meaning
predicted that it would crash and
benefited all comes down to Christian
Bale's character just reading uh what
the bonds were composed of yeah like and
and there's a line like with your dad
going no one reads the Geneva Accord no
one reads the mortgages listen to what
I'm saying I'm bored and I love what I'm
saying yeah no one reads the bundles of
mortgages that make up comprise a bond
that you can then bet against so he read
stayed up a couple nights I guess and
just read thousands of mortgages and
assessed how stable they were and that's
the difference between that's the 5T to
the stage y that it wasn't [__] sexy
interesting fun cool it was a uh when I
say weird I say I say that with love it
was a outlying
individual who smelled something funky
and then did the boring ass reading and
that's what your your dad did here's
where I'm going to take it I think I'm
I'm so I'm I'm one of the I'm optimistic
about artificial intelligence I think
it's already done you are yeah you want
to we can talk about that in a minute
yeah whenever you get a chance I'm going
to lie
down
go up I'd love I know I'm excited for
your
take I am but well one of the things
that AI has done is is I'm going to get
the science language wrong but there's
something I'm not even going to try to
say well I'm going to grave you on it I
know well the people listening are going
to be mad cuz somebody stop it okay just
[__] get off his back you're going to
get what I'm trying to say even if I
don't say correctly but in the past it
took about six years for one scientific
team to crack I'm going to say this is
the part that's going to be wrong but
one of the human genomes or something
some in Inc comprehensively complex
bundle of DNA RNA all this [__] stuff
would take about six years for a team to
crack one of them then they programmed
an AI to do it it took six years to
program it and since then it's done
thousands of them so we understand the
human body way better because a program
was let loose here's this leads somewhat
to my optimism ai ai did it that's true
thousands [__] yeah no that's cuz that's
the
um that's one of the things that drove
uh cystic fibrosis is um to to finding
uh it is not a cure but it is uh it is
literally uh lengthen the lives yeah
because they they could test a pill a b
what you just basically said they test a
bill a pill a billion different ways a
billion different we had this we had
this we had this I can be like chrisan I
think in 10 years maybe less it's going
to be very quaint that people like
Christian Bale's character I'm sorry I
can't remember the real guy's name used
to just stay up for three nights reading
mortgages when an AI could just be like
oh you want to find a pattern in the
mortgages I can do that in 0.001 seconds
and that's really really cool but I
think what's going to happen is that
outlying phenomenon of of intense data
analysis we're already doing it I could
go on chat GPT and say summarize what's
the name of your book we'll plug it uh
we plug
uh plug nothing sacred for God's sake
it's an oldie but a goodie nothing
sacred you could say summarize I I had
it summarize my book yeah I was like
we'll see about this summarize Pete
Holmes's book comedy sex god in 500
Words and by God it [__] did it and I
was I was like I I was humble cuz I was
like it's too subtle takes a weird left
in the middle it completely changes it
got that it was like it was like and
then it and I'm like holy [__] so what
I'm saying is my summary would be I got
it for
free and that was I got it for free and
it's been a very sturdy coaster for many
many years in the black household you
see what I'm saying so this leads to
some of the AI optimism is I'm like the
problems that can be solved through
boring ass stuff that usually takes
either a mental anomaly meaning I just
have a higher tolerance for boring data
are going to be like common place you we
can we can set things out to look for
things that used to take months of
sweating and grueling that we hate doing
we'll be able to have access to that
information much much faster that leads
to some of my optimism and but that
would be but then there has to be you
know which is uh the the guy who went in
front of Congress who's one of the three
who came up with AI yeah going you got
to [__] help us right we've got to
have you've got to create boundaries yes
and that's our problem I I I have what
you say about AI is ABS is true true
really and I really have it's glad you
reminded me of it of something good
instead of just yeah well I mean I you
know because it's also you know my
acting go how many we've been dealing
with AI it's like how many of you you
know you call the you you call up the
pharmacy and you just you need to you
need to find a a a pill and you don't
have the the thing that tells you what
the number is and it literally it's like
if you're calling for a b c you know I
haven't even filled in the and they're
already laughing so I don't well you
can't laugh because I've got to fill
this in yeah yeah that's right but it's
true you know and then you're you know
and then I kind you know you're
screaming get me a human being get and
AI is not that smart I understand you
want an operator Louis but right now
it's just you and me so if you could
cool the beans just for a moment it will
get sophisticated enough where imagine
an AI that was you or me that that could
have like social Grace and be like look
I get it you don't want to talk to a Rob
imagine it's coming it's coming I
understand but believe me I can help you
more than Phil you want to talk to Phil
it roasts Phil this guy just had a heavy
lunch he's half asleep I'm perfectly
capable of helping you what do you think
Phil can do just does 20 minutes on Phil
you're like this guy's all right like
you'd be one over or you wouldn't know
you're talking to an you wouldn't know
yeah you wouldn't know you know here's
my I'm going to load this back to you
yeah and it goes into somewhat of a a a
spiritual B I think everything the way
the universe
works is sort of helping us wake up
realize ourselves evolve and I think AI
is going to do that and I this is my
prediction I don't think this is
actually going to happen but let's just
consider it it's going to help us
realize how insane we are cuz once you
develop something that doesn't have an
ego you're going to realize that human
motivation is like let's eat the elderly
right why is that funny it's because we
live in a world where it's like at least
it's for something I'll [__] kill you
if I get something if I can have sex
with it if I can taste it if it can give
me status if it can give me space I want
to go to Bora Bora and sit on a balcony
smoke a cigar these are all stimulants
and and Status things white head white
earbuds the newest phone it's all
[__] you know this I know this but
an AI is not going to war starts in the
minds of men it says at at un these are
[__] ego trips and once we develop
and the AI develops itself to a point
where it's egoless you'll be talking to
something that this is
all you know optimistic will only
reflect back to us how [__] nuts
we've been because we'll go like how do
we do this and it's like why would you
want to do that like it won't understand
everything we do is to have sex make
more of ourselves and and status that
doesn't make any sense you won't be able
to disrespect an ultimate intelligence
you won't be able to offend an ultimate
intelligence an ultimate intelligence
won't want to make more of itself it
won't want to relax it won't want to own
land it won't want to dominate people
does that does any of that make sense no
it does make sense and it would make
sense if they give it a voice like uh
George Clooney Jim well actually Jimmy
Stewart yeah you know Gary Cooper you
know it has to have that kind of a voice
because it literally well why would you
want to do that well that's your money
and my money we need to band together
have a universal salary it's all nuts
money's nuts property's nuts food is
it's all [__] nuts but the but and
this is where I will get on the offramp
with you but only go so far because I
there in and out bur man a nice oh good
then you let's stop [__] this we're
going to take a few
minutes just to relax and think about
the in- andout Breer which is artificial
intelligence on a whole other level it
sure is yeah no but that we um we you
know the the universe has been telling
us that forever that we're nuts yeah and
that's the universe screams it every day
the universe as soon as you yesterday
were driving I
mean you you don't see it all the time
but I'm driving through Colorado through
like the where swatches of it where no
one is and through the mountains just go
in the word Colorado those O's are very
empty
yes you're looking at a map and you
wrote Colorado on it a lot of empty
space so you you you know basically It's
shouting at the the the the universe
shouts at you you're [__] nuts so I
mean I think there is the my problem is
this this is where I stumbl wait when
did it shout to you though what did what
was it about driving through Colorado
that sh it was just the the the whole
landscape oh the quietness quiet it was
quiet enough for you to go like stunning
it's like yeah you know what whatever
you [__] are doing does not compare
to this it's like the joke I have was I
lived in Colorado and the mountains were
there you know what those mountains said
to people don't [__] go over the
mountain yeah don't go over the mountain
that's why God put the mountain there
okay so we went over the mountain all
right so we did you know you're not
supposed to eat the apple so we did all
right so we did that but you know by
being in the midst of it you don't you
just kind of go this is glorious this is
this is all the other stuff is
meaningless in comparative to this you
know that that you know and you could
turn the radio on while you're watching
this and listen to how we're going to be
the government's going to shut down in a
day and a half and all these people are
going to get [__] and then you look
here and go what is the matter with us
yeah yeah yeah that's right that's right
and can I unpack that a little bit going
over the mountain
it's like what does it feel like to not
go over the mountain right it's un it's
unbearable it's there if if if you're
not at peace if you're not like your dad
watching a dirty movie and his so it's
all specialness that's kind of what I'm
saying is if AI was
actually uh you know like almost like a
Godlike thing it wouldn't be interested
in specialist everything we do is for
specialist including eating the Apple my
inter interpretation of the Garden of
Eden is eat this apple you'll be kicked
out of Oneness of perfect Unity
identityless Unity though no specialness
the nakedness isn't I'm not wearing
clothes it's I don't even have an
identity I'm not I'm I'm naked I'm zero
and I'm zero with God and I'm zero with
Eve and I'm zero with the garden but
it's just one zero and then the voice of
the ego the snake says eat this apple
you'll get kicked out but you'll be
you'll be [__] special and that is
what I think it's it's a great origin
story that's what we're doing I'm not
saying this in an aggressive way even a
nice loving conversation like this
there's elements of it it's like am I
getting enough imagine if I wouldn't let
you talk like I know I'm doing that a
little bit but like that's a winning
like and I get to be like special that's
what's so offensive about someone who
doesn't listen it's like they're only
special now I'm Vanishing and it's
[__] lonely we came here to be
special and climb mountains and and
break rules and and we'll do it at the
cost of our own equinity our peace our
Oneness our connectedness does that any
of that relate oh no yeah I could tell
you you were enjoying it I'm just
throwing it back to
you no I got it no it's U but my the the
problem with AI is is just that you know
and part of it is just the joke but part
of is the reality of it is is that I I
see the planet as being a collection of
of of idiots we're just dopes we're dumb
we're dumb and so then there were three
of the dumbest people uh the Smart Ones
of the dumb ones but just smart they're
just a little bit smarter than the dumb
that's how much more they that's right
we're the we're this dumb and then the
only reason and they're they took it
just that much more they got just a
little bit more of brain and that there
I I can't really TR trust the the the
smartest to the dumb one so I'm hoping
AI kind of connects the dots because I
don't know it's going to take you know
what we need at this point is you you is
you had someone like uh an Einstein well
you have those thinkers that's or the
Beatles where you have somebody who is
all of a sudden got that Clear Vision
cuz that's what we lack now we yeah I
hear you you know that one that kind of
few people who kind of get it and and
here's I was just going to throw in
terms of of AI because I know it was a
part of I'm sure it was a part of
creating the uh the MRNA the the vaccine
yeah uh here's one that they just thre
oh you think they used AI to make the
vaccine I I have a feeling yeah because
of only because of
um of the uh you know the throwing the
pill in and which pill's going to work
oh this it's just a conjecture on my
part but today they sense they gave it
the uh I mean this is the kind of [__]
that's got to be done in terms of it's a
minor but those the two who came up with
it were were're given the Nobel Prize
today oh were they really yeah oh wow
and that and that I will announce here
on Peter's show is going to [__] things
up because then that whole group of
people go well they didn't deserve the
Nobel Prize
they what yes they deserve the Nobel
Prize you [__]
idiots God damn it and now we're going
to have to argue it you know yeah yeah
yeah and so part of what we're we're
dealing with too is is that you're
you've pushed toward getting over the
mountain and then we got a whole bunch
of people going uh no I'm going to I
need I need to stay here at the bottom
mountain and uh look for the smell of
swamp gas I mean that's yeah it's those
people pulling from behind that don't I
mean that doesn't it and that's kind of
like you need those people who leap the
boundaries yeah and they used to listen
to
them right no that's true we could be
going into a we're already in like a
post truuth era we could be in like a
post post truth yeah everybody gets
their own micro climate of truth and
that's certainly already happening when
I when I try and find compassion for
people that are like the people that
made the vaccine don't deserve the Nobel
Prize I really hear
like like my dad the Irish poet as he's
saying maybe I won't see you next time I
think we're all pretty
heartbroken at how vulnerable we are and
when when someone makes a vaccine and
says you need this or you'll die it will
always be compelling and I can relate to
this to go [__] you you know what I mean
I'm not like it's like we're like
flowers in the sidewalk and it's a busy
sidewalk people flowers are getting
crushed all the time and then the
flowers to make ourselves feel better go
like no we're good we're [__] flowers
I'm what am I I'm an American American
flower yeah I'm a rich flower I'm a
powerful flower I'm a sexy flower you're
still a flower in the sidewalk and and
and the feet are coming but like it's
it's like even smoking talking about how
you were a smoker smoking is like [__]
you I eat [__] that's like its own
version of like and then there's such a
tenderness in a vaccine there's such a
humility in a vaccine to go like I can't
can't I can't and we're
not we're not a culture that really
admires humility I know I say this
everybody I'm so sorry but watch any
movie watch Top Gun watch and I love
these movies Mission Impossible watch
the bo I like Top
Gun it was good in the theater then I
watched it on a TV and I was like why
did I ever like this but in the theater
was one of the greatest things oh yeah
you should have seen it in the theater
no you shouldn't have go live your life
Lou don't don't go see Top Gun in the
theater no I will now I'm going I said
it cuz you're that impressionable really
I must but these movies look at the
Avengers they're
all basically even though the Avengers
are kind of an ensemble movie but it's
really just like a lot of loners go and
kick ass and only accept help at the
last minute like if you're about to die
then it's okay if I come in and shoot
the guy on you but and then move on and
act like that never happened it's very
Macho or you see what I'm saying we're
not a like vaccine like we don't we
don't like that story does that make
sense that's why we're like [__] these
scientists but we did like that story
and then we stopped liking the story
yeah I see what you're saying and that's
what's weird and we stopped liking the
story because of this yeah in part so
that we have separate realities in part
I mean that we're argu look I mean the
basic is is that we are we we would be
in better shape if we agreed on what
reality is we are on an acid trip and
part of the room thinks there's snakes
everywhere okay and you cannot go there
when you're on acid just a tip just a
tip but that's really part of the deal
true you know whenever I'm in
a this happens sometimes when I'm on
psychedelics but I
actually uh yesterday I just had a very
beautiful morning and centered myself to
a pretty psychedelic place but just
sitting there and I it was beautiful and
you know how I did it I just closed my
eyes and listened to everything that was
happening around me I wouldn't even even
call it meditation there was no effort
just kind of appreciating that like I am
a field of awareness and nothing is
outside of it and there's a bird and it
seems so far away but really it's just a
quiet noise right here you know what I
mean I add the story that it's over
there but really it's it's all happening
on the white piece of paper that is you
it's all written on you I just got
[__] tripped out on that then I went
downstairs and I was looking around I
was like oh my daughter and and my wife
didn't have this experience you know
what I mean like I'm having a different
experience and sometimes I have that on
you take something like MDMA that makes
you very loving you're like whoa It's
all how you feel like we're and we're
all separate units having these and what
I hear you saying is like we need to get
on the same page like it would help us
if we could get on the same page cuz
some of us are having a very bad trip
there's a lot of bad trips going on out
there very bad Tri and that you I mean
cuz the joke I did was just you know
there was an acceptance of the polio
vaccine there was no if sins or buts
there was no discussion right it's like
do you want your kid and I said you know
want your kid to be in an irong or not
this is can you debate about whether you
should get it this or not you know you
can debate it all you want you cannot
deny that it worked okay even though
people you know there were less people
dying okay that's all you wanted you
didn't the rest of the argument is
insane yeah the m mRNA virus left your
it left I mean what they gave you left
you it's not there it is not like a flu
shot get a grip [__] listen when
people try to explain it to you rather
than don't go there okay they're trying
to talk to you yeah take the earplugs
out it's and because in mRNA was the
step toward the next thing which is
curing cancer so if and all of those
people who are bitching about this yeah
are are going to and what they'll
benefit from it and we'll won't go to a
hospital and then they go you know uh we
we don't have to give you chemo what
we're going to do is give you this
they're going to go what are you going
to now say no yeah I don't want that I
want the I want the hard stuff right
it's real gun to your head gun to your
head and you're like yeah and that's
when they kind to go oh yeah no I'm
gonna have to rely on science because
I'm GNA die [__] you all right right
this was this is not something that has
taken place out of the context I mean
it's just and a lot of it I still
believe a lot of it had to do with the p
that this period of time when when
someone sits down to write it there's
going to be a hell of a book about what
it did to the human Psych the pandemic
yeah I I agree with you you know you've
come out with this positive attitude and
I'm still trying to figure out why I'm
75 I should like
like your dad like I go down for
breakfast and you go I don't I'm never
going to forget that that's really you
know what's interesting and maybe I'm
not the first I'm certainly not the
first to notice this but it's like you
said this all changed with this these
micro realities that we're all living in
are very curated to
us and what I'm saying you held up the
phone and I'm like it's even like
there's so much customization in the
polio time there wasn't as much
customization you got your pants at the
pants store if I'm pick piing it
correctly but there wasn't like 9,000
pants you could even look at it like
video games when I was growing up video
games you were Mario now you play a
video game you make a guy or a woman or
or a [__] orc that looks exactly like
you or exactly like what you want
there's something wrong with that but
like once you introduce into the
bloodstream of humanity ultimate
customization a choice of whether or not
you take a vaccine is just another
Choice it's another identity making
choice this another thing that the AI
would understand at all that's a very
good way to look at it that's an
identity maker it's an identity maker
well again in the interest of compassion
I know there this is something we say on
the show all the time if I were you I'd
be you so that take an antivaxer that
hates the Nobel PRI and all that and I
was like if I was him I'd be him yeah
because there's a possibility get and we
know it's true if I grew up with that
person's experiences in that community
with access to what he had access to and
didn't have access to or whatever he I'd
be him and if he was me and had access
to what I had access to and the
relationships I had and the parents that
I had and this and that and that he'd be
me so there's something kind of
beautiful to just dropping and going
like it's not the your identity isn't
the end all be all and when I say
identity I really just mean the
character you're playing and this weird
trip
where but I I like to
go I know there's a me that would have
been at a rally with the masket it's cut
out and I'm going [__] you [__] you I
know because there is one one yeah you
know how I know I could be it because
someone else is it yeah that doesn't
excuse anything I'm just saying it
increases understanding no but it also
increases empathy that's what I'm saying
like you said about the othering yeah
yeah it's like I kind you know growing
up thinking everyone was going hell I
don't anymore helped me and primed me to
understand flat earthers you know what I
mean oh I'm just saying like I know kind
of what it's like to have a weird belief
somebody I was know except that well
it's true but except that one is so
weird somebody I said it the other day
in I forget in what context on some
interview radio or press thing and I
said like the like the flat earthers and
the iy paused and went you know see
here's what I don't he went into it he
well he actually said no he didn't go
into it but what he said which was
interesting he said
I don't know what the advantage is of
thinking that uh that the Earth is that
yeah he said I don't know what advantage
you get from thinking that you know it
he said either way it's the same it's
there's not like oh I've one up you I
actually really like this guy I like
that interpretation because that's how I
feel about simulation Theory it doesn't
matter if we're plugged into a
simulation the
fundamental in fact the base ele element
of what you are which is awareness is
the feeling is the Sens it's not even a
sensation it's not a feeling but the
knowledge that I am like I this image is
being given to me and then there's
something in me that knows it yeah and I
hear it and I know it and I learn it I
know the thing that knows if it's
knowing a simulation or it's knowing
reality what's the [__] difference
the mystery of knowing of being is still
there and that you could call that God
or you like maybe we talked about this
last time but I like the Jewish uh you
know Moses says to God who are you and
he says I am that I am he's say I am
amness I am beingness that sense of like
I'm aware awareness itself so what
you're aware of in every mystical
tradition is secondary so if it's a
simulation or if it's a dance or if it's
Maya or if it's play or if it's a acid
trip or if it's a dream the mystery
remains and we can still investigate
that mystery even if reality isn't
ultimately uh what what is real it's
just [__] I'm feeling this and I go
it's real and and then you go uh that
step two because there's the Sim I wrote
a bit about the in this book I wrote
about religions you know my religious
experience and stumbled on this article
about the simulation because yeah you
know that we this is all we're all just
simul and I was like and I went [__] I
got this far without nobody needed to
tell me this I don't need to think about
this this is like but it's you put it in
a in a in a in a well you you you stated
it well in terms of of what it could
mean I was just like uh stunned by that
and then and what it meant and what it
meant in terms of my belief yeah of how
this all works because it's like no I'm
not I can't go there I I refuse you know
because somebody's simulating someone
simulating someone then it's just
simulation tur all the way down yeah see
but it is it is Turtles all the way down
that's actually kind of what I'm saying
is nothing's changed the Hindus would
say it's a dream it's it's she I forget
if it's shiva's dream or whatever but
it's or whatever I just dismiss a faith
whatever uh but it's a dream I like the
food or it's
play Humanity has always taken spiritual
ident uh ideas and explain them using
the height of Technology I've said this
before but it's like the Greeks or was
it the Romans had aqueducts so they were
like the brain is like a series of
aqueducts and now we go the brain is
like a computer or we can say reality is
a simulation it's like a video game it's
like a a VR it's like the matrix it's
like we're we're still trying to explain
if you will if you'll allow
me this isn't real this isn't the end of
the story what we're exper your
experiential happenings the plot of the
movie isn't the point what happen
happens to Lewis if he does this or does
that isn't the point the point is the
origin and God is really just a word for
origin it's just like the how can we
reduce this to its smallest indivisible
element yeah and whether we call the I
kind of like saying that this is a
distraction or Maya illusion play
simulation dream I get a lot out of
Dream It's just to go okay so then the
point of this is to just let it go and
find the source of if that makes sense
but finding the finding the source of it
is uh basically in the N piece yeah and
it's you yeah yeah and it's you but but
do you see oh boy we are really this is
I really hate talking to
you do you see it as uh because this is
something I kind of I I I don't I I
don't think about it as much as you do
but um but I've thought about it a lot
and that uh um was that do are we all
the world is are each one of us
everything yeah I think and we are that
yeah yeah yeah we are that okay all
right then we agree and uh you'll be
able to find us in a Psychiatric clinic
near you they'll be studying no that's
so good though like there's a lot of
people like psychosis and Enlightenment
have a lot very very close they're bed
fellows well the guy the on the street
yesterday who was I was getting on the
uh getting on in I think it was um Salt
Lake City who was had a shaww over him
and was I was going out was like 10:00
in the morning to get on the the bus to
head to Grand Junction and he stopped me
he said you're Louis black said I used
to have money I doing pretty well now
I'm homeless and but I've been I've
followed your work for a long time he
said and uh and I'm Jesus Christ
was like yeah and he said in many ways
you're Jesus Christ and then it would
and it was like one of those things if I
had the 10 minutes yeah I would go
through the conversation with him but
like within another minute and a half as
I was getting toward the bus I was like
oh no this would not be this would
there's a little too much of course well
the ego can't come along yeah that
there's a great part of be here now
where if you sit at the right hand of
God and you're Lewis Black you'll that's
ins sanity you go I Louis black and
Jesus Christ that's insanity if the
smallest piece of awareness is the same
awareness that Jesus had but you could
Al that guy is also Hitler you know what
I'm saying like tikn Han wrote a
beautiful uh poem about this we we
reference it all the time where he's
like he's like I'm a beautiful frog in a
pond but I'm also the snake that eats
the Frog and and he takes that to some
very uncomfortable places but if you're
everything you have to kind of be like
that's that's everything psychosis
always goes to this is the phenomenon of
everybody's past life they were Marie
Antoinette you know what I mean it's
like that's that's the ego coming in the
back door you're have you're getting an
ego identity trip out of your spiritual
trip you know what I'm saying so yeah
you pick the most famous person of all
time yeah okay I mean sure that ramdas
visited his brother in a psych wward and
he was like I'm Jesus Christ and he was
like I am too and he was like but we
didn't mean it the same way yeah it's
it's it's a weird and did what is the
line a friend of mine just sent me by
him uh that uh we're all just walking
each other home yeah yeah that's a
that's it that's really a great that's a
that's the closest I've read in a long
time to
um to finding some sense of piece of
what we are doing that we are that
somebody once
described I went to a great you rarely
go to a great funeral where somebody
actually is speaking and tells you
something about yeah that gives you
comfort yeah cuz mostly it's you know
they take you know but this it's mostly
their snacks afterwards exactly please
relax there there are snacks there
snacks and liquor uh it was a Greek
Orthodox also which made it interesting
and he said I don't know um what the he
I don't understand people when it comes
to and I'm this is I'm bastardizing this
cuz I really wish I had a copy of it cuz
it was one of these things I [__] who
knew that this guy was going to [__]
nail it drop it yeah right here you know
and but basically he was just on a
simple of saying we were
somewhere and then we showed up here and
when we leave we go somewhere he said
this is just a this is just part of the
journey and you go well why the [__]
don't they say that more often yeah
that's great well I mean it's it's just
it's true it's as true as as we're going
into that this is it and that's all that
happens and uh yeah and I find that I
just
don't um I just have never uh believed
that even you know even and I've not
been given that Comfort by being born
and raises Jewish you know but I know my
friends who Judy Gold yeah um you know
she and I talked about Judaism stuff and
she says a totally different take
tonight wow you know and uh and we all
kind of find it that way but I think
that that that whole idea of this is a
journey
is and your need is my need it's not
just a thought experiment is if I'm like
there only is one awareness and it
happens to be in you and
me uh but it's the same then I realize
that we have some despite what whatever
differences we have we're really just
trying to get home and there's something
really beautiful about that and it helps
us put a lot of things aside and go like
I get it this world's [__] weird
let's not even worry too much about it
like what's going on what do you think's
going on yeah yeah it's really cool I
just read this morning it was like the
greatest of all the coons is I just the
letter I and I can't really do this rert
Spyro who I'm obsessed with he can do it
he can guide people through like I but
it's like when if you're feeling
stressed who Rupert Rupert spy he's he's
a teacher he's uh I don't know how to
describe him CU he's not particularly uh
religious but he's like ramanana Mahari
do you know Raman Mahari self self-
inquiry they say inquiry because they're
British but it's just going like what do
you mean when you say I like and
nobody's really talking about this but
he's talking about like that presence
that's aware of your thoughts and your
feelings
and he has all these brilliant ways of
explaining it he's like if you ask
someone to describe this room to them
that talk about chairs and microphones
and coffee and Lewis and Pete but no one
would describe the space in the room and
he's like and your awareness is like
that space so when it comes to like fear
and what are we doing and and real peace
that I I'm getting the sense that your
dad tasted is recognizing that you're
the space in the room and the stuff
comes goes like what what is the
constant if you can think of a a memory
from your childhood and ask yourself was
there a sense of being yeah there was so
eight years old it was there here you're
75 it's still here so there is a
constant and asking yourself when I say
I what do I mean it can't be Pete Pete
has been so many different [__]
things and it's not my thoughts those
are changing my beliefs change my
feelings change in this conversation in
this little moment they've changed so
it's it's the presence that's watching
them and then when you can lean into
that and not be afraid and learn to
trust it and to know that its qualities
are spacious and peaceful and kind these
are all not quite right but loving then
you get a little bit less afraid yeah
yeah yeah let's do some
[Music]
cocaine that was my great
discovery we really got there and then
we just blew rails
yeah yeah we'll see you it's we got
things to do that that when I discovered
that uh uh that cocaine I was i' done it
for a bit and then I woke up I had a
really stupid night and woke up I was
using it to write late into the night
and I was using it to to finish up a
play and I and I literally it was one
sentence that was written over and over
and over again that I just had you
Shining de I I just but I've written not
but it was it was literally like this
black line on the thing I'd written I
never got anything really written that I
know I don't even know what I wrote and
I woke up and said that's that that's
enough of that that's enough of that and
within a day I realized I said what was
I doing it for and I realized I was
doing it for anxiety the essentially the
high on cocaine is anxiety is anxiety it
it is yeah and you
drink and you drink in sense to calm it
down and then you do more to kind of get
that just right Jerk it up again and
then I went I said I don't if I need
this I can call my mother that is good
that is very good yeah that's what uh
melany uh used to call anxiety-free
cocaine that's when when we were close a
long time ago it'd be like free cocaine
and I was like that's exactly right wow
I love that um by let me plug it cuz I
can't do it I said that I can't do it as
well as he can but there's a book that
rert wrote called You Are are the
happiness you seek which is brilliant
it's really really great yeah that's the
plug let's close with this Lou can you
think of a time in your life when you
laughed really really really really hard
we've been talking about your parents
maybe it was with your parents maybe
someone fell maybe someone
farted there were a lot of big laughs
I've had in my life and the biggest as I
remember it yeah was because it was not
connected to anything and um and it was
I was on
um
masculine and I was lying in the grass
and staring at the
grass and uh say what you want about
drugs they get you outside yeah they do
and I'm not an outdoorsy
person but I was out there and I'm
sitting there and I'm by myself totally
there was my friends were wandering
around doing whatever and
I laughed at the grass for like three
minutes I could and I can't explain what
it was about yeah and it wasn't a
thought yeah it wasn't like oh the gra
it was literally just this entire burst
of like yeah this you know like it may
have been that how stupid is this a
[__] grass really it put me you
know and I and you know that whole thing
your brain does in the movies kind of
the movie would be
you know boy you know I never really
have thought about grass and one should
think about grass and then that kind of
none of that it was just sheer Joy yeah
cuz lwis can't come it's kind of what we
were just talking about yeah all the
great profound even the space I was in
yesterday morning I can't I can't I
don't get to go Pete doesn't even get to
remember it that's what makes it so
precious drugs are otherwise you're
there and you're like why should
anything exist that's the great
contemplative prompt why should anything
exist what it's [__] nuts it's crazy
I love that answer it also reminds me of
laughing at grass I smoked some pot that
was called LSD and I was like we'll see
about that and boy oh boy yeah I was
like this is like LSD and the grass was
it w this could have been in a movie it
was like a cliche it was like like like
you know they're like waving at me and
talking to me and looked like a little
world and I was like lost in it I was
like that's some strong grass
man no [__]
yeah they were talking to me yeah I
can't believe they listen to this
podcast no nobody's
listening well it's good you mean the
grass it's good it's really a pleasure
you know I love talking with you man I I
feel a real kinship with you and I
appreciate the time and what are we
plugging we'll plug in the intro too
well I'm on tour and uh I'll be coming
to your neighborhood and good luck oh
your and your podcast is called and my
is called Lewis Black's rant cast rcast
and you can go to Lewis black.com and
you can find all the but I you know
wherever wherever I am in the calendar
you I'll be in Cleveland Cincinnati you
know and I'll be I'm going to Salt Lake
this week are you yeah where are you
hilarities oh hilarities yes yeah oh
that's I it was great and there's a uh
and I will do this plug because uh
Walter's austeria is one of the five
best Italian restaurants I've ever eaten
it's in Utah it's in Utah what is it
called Walter v a l t e r s okay
austeria okay o s t e r a i if you like
pasta it's it's really remarkable but he
he's passed away I we we would on
occasion drive through you know if we
were heading west we would stop in Salt
Lake to eat at the restaur no kidding
it's a great it's really wow okay well
thank you for that I recommend the
temple that you might cleanse yourself
oh yeah yes so I recommend the magic
underwear for
12295 I did go to the animatronic Jesus
at the end of the temple is the oh I
didn't go in the temple there's an
animatronic Jesus you haven't been in I
didn't go in oh you [__] go in are
you serious we do this whole [__] oh
I put faith in this i t it I just didn't
go in Oh for crying out loud he's a
shy this man given the opportunity to
reach out to one of the 75,000 great
religions and he P he just mormonism's
in the top
75,000 but you literally take the tour
yeah okay well there's an animatronic je
oh and you will write me uh you if they
taking the animatronic Jesus out due to
coid or whatever it'll be disappointing
it is I mean I'm just your reaction to
that story will be spectacular I'm in oh
no you've got you got 10 minutes really
I think so it's like Disneyland It's a
Great Big Beautiful Tomorrow that one
it's pretty close to I mean it is of
presidents yeah it's it's I don't
remember I just remember going don't
laugh you can't laugh you just can't
just don't laugh it was like the Oral
Roberts when I saw that one when I went
into the in Oral Roberts University
animatronic hisory well there's a kind
of a whole thing there that you kind of
go you know can't laugh this this part
of the story you can't laugh at that
part of the story and I bet we could get
a private laughing aloud
tour we'll go yeah really well Lou thank
you so much man this was a real pleasure
always a pleasure yeah would you say
keep it crispy it's how we it's how we
close you say keep it crispy I'm going
to say keep it crispy yeah you're going
to say keep it crispy what's that in
reference to it's just like uh you know
Stay classy San Diego it's just like a
way of signing
off nothing bad nothing stupid you won't
won't be a fool and you said it last
time yeah you know you're safe I I've
said other stuff on this that I'll be sh
within 20 minutes that's the only thing
so I do me a favor folks huh keep it
crispy there it is there it is thank you
Louis what what a
pleasure oh yeah you made it win you
made it win you it with oh yeah you made
it you made it you made it with all yeah
you made it with you made it you made it
with oh yeah